y tal muy buenos días raúl pues lo
cierto es que sí que en los centros de
votación hay muchísima gente ahora mismo
no hay se han dispensado un poco las
multitudes porque está lloviendo pero sí
que el flujo constante de votantes en
los centros de votación especialmente
aquí en florida es algo habitual en todo
el estado por eso a muchos aseguran que
se podrían batir récords de
participación incluso superar los 150
millones de votantes principalmente
porque ya han votado 55 millones de
personas tanto por correo de forma
anticipada en todo eeuu eso representa
casi el 40 por ciento de todo el
electorado que votó en 2016 tal y como
apuntaba el presidente barack obama
estuvo de hecho aquí en la ciudad de
miami pues intentando a cautivar el voto
especialmente de las minorías
afroamericanos y latinos que pueden ser
clave también para estas elecciones
mientras que el presidente de donald
trump hizo su
ejerció su derecho al voto anticipado en
webs por la ciudad donde él está
registrado anthony que usted lo dijo
flory de esclava entonces en esta
elección pero no es el único estado le
pregunto que otros están en la mira de
las campañas y además cuáles son los
planes de los candidatos para hoy
domingo
si de hecho una de las cosas que tienen
en la mira especialmente el partido
demócrata es no perder a aquellos
estados en los que se confiaba en un
principio que se iban a ganar eso pasó
en 2016 cuando hillary clinton perdió
estados clave como wisconsin pensilvania
michigan por eso la campaña demócrata
está haciendo especial atención se está
poniendo especial atención a esos
estados para asegurarse que van a
convertirse en estados azules por lo
tanto van a conseguir los votos
electorales necesarios para que yo vaya
bien pueda sumar y llegar eventualmente
a la casa blanca mientras tanto también
el partido republicano también está muy
pendiente de esos votos
y estaremos también muy pendientes de
cómo evoluciona esta jornada electoral